Réjean Tremblay, chroniqueur
sportif.
Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir Patrice.
- Au mois de mai dernier, avec
des reportages là-dessus. Il n's
l'alignement du Canadien. Sacrée
tout un tollé.Je vous montre une
nombre de Québécois dans le club
canadien n'a pas arrêté debaiss%
91, rendu 4 % en 2020. Il y a
cinq joueurs actuellement dans
l'alignement. Réjean Tremblay
dit qu'il faut plus de joueurs
dans le alignement. Ça va
changer selon vous?
- la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on
fasse cette conversation.
Monsieur Legault, à cause des
sondages et de sa formalité a eu
un bon flair des gens au Québec.
Puis, je pense être bien senti
qu'il y avait un espèce de
mécontentement, pas une déprime,
mais elle hockey elle sport
nationale. Le sport aussi
communiqué le mieux avec
l'ensemble du Québec.
Les séries éliminatoires l'an
dernier. Le simple fait que
quelqu'un comme le premier
ministre du Québec réunisse des
gens la qualité des gens au
moins il y a une espèce de
réveille-matin qui sonne. Ça,
c'est important. Mais la
réaction des médias, la réaction
de télécommunications pas justes
de sport. Je trouve ça
important. Ces deux éléments à
société qui est important le
hockey. D'ailleurs, on n'en
parle ce soir à l'endroit où on
fait nos grands dossiers à tous
les soirs. Ça, il a réussi à
faire parler de ça. Vous dîtes,
il y a beaucoup de monde le
comité. On lui donne quelques
mois. On embrasse large.
L'équipement coûte cher aux
parents, le manque de jeunes
dans les équipes, le lien entre
les cols, le fait qu'il n'y ait
pas ces deux filles. On embrasse
très large.
- Très large, et je pense qu'il
faut bien comprendre que ça va
être une espèce de remue
méninges de haut niveau. Moi,
j'espère qu'ils auront le budget
envoyé quelqu'un top comme
Danièle Sauvageau par exemple en
Suède et en Finlande. La
population de la Finlande est
inférieure à celle du Québec.
Or, leur progression a été
fulgurante au niveau du hockey
amateur alors que s'installe au
Québec. Mais ça, l'argent, je
pense que le modèle du
bénévolat, non seulement c'est
parfois dangereux, mais en plus
je pense que c'est incompétent.
Falloir trouver une autre façon,
mais aussi trouver une autre
façon de financer des programmes
à travers des professionnels
pour diriger, coacher et ramener
le plaisir dans les arénas.
- D'ailleurs, premier ministre
n'a parlé deux ou trois fois en
tant que n'a pu de bon sens. Les
parents deviennent fous, les
arénas sont un lieu presque
malsain maintenant. Il faut
ramener le goût de jouer, de
mettre les bâtons de la glace,
de jouer au hockey.
- Il ne faut jamais oublier une
chose. La langue française est
extrêmement bien faite. On joue
au hockey. On ne travaille pas.
Les jeunes qui arrivent à huit
ou neuf ans, qu'elle je ne cesse
de s'amuser avec une pression
qui n'a pas de bon sens.
C'est bien beau, à l'état et les
Canadiens dans le sens du poil,
elle est à sa conférence de
presse dans le Centre Bell,
je pense que Monsieur Legault
aurait pu on pourrait compter
également sur les Canadiens de
Montréal, parce que c'est quand
même, c'est l'institution qui
représente le hockey. Les jeunes
voulaient jouer pour les
Canadiens. Je n'avais l'espoir,
un jour, de jouer avec les
Canadiens. Quelqu'un comme Serge
Savard et avant lui haver une
règle en or. On n'est pas
supposé échapper un seul jeune
francophone au Québec.
C'est quelque le moindre mot de
talent, il faut qu'il joue pour
les Canadiens. À parts égales
entre les Canadiens. Depuis 20
ans, vous avez les statistiques,
le repêchage non seulement il
est abominable, mais en plus il
exclut pratiquement complètement
tout ce qui est francophone.
C'est devenu un handicap d'être
francophone.
- Est-ce que vous pensez que ça
va changer?
il y a eu une épiphanie les
Canadiens?
- Oui, je pense que ça va
changer. Parce que à un moment
donné ça devient une question de
cash aussi. Deuxièmement là, la
pression, et notre comité, qui
vont utiliser qui vont se
pencher, c'est impossible
une des 14 personnes, peut-être
notre travail serait facile.
- Merci de nous avoir parlé. On
va suivre les travaux de ce
comité qui va les vite en
princi